a vast convoy of russian armored
vehicles stretched out over tens of
kilometers is advancing on kiev
ukraine's capital
the city has been hit by numerous
missiles
russia has warned there's more to come
those who haven't fled are prepared for
a grueling siege
many are ready to fight
if the convict actually does press into
the city it will meet extremely
determined resistance
the economist's correspondent tim judah
is in kiev
[Music]
i spent time with the territorial
defense force which is the new force of
um civilians there are thousands of them
i you meet them absolutely all over the
place and they are extremely ready to
fight at various key points around the
city the territorial defense has dug
trenches um and the other thing that's
been done um are that checkpoints have
been put across you know major roads
that's to say we've got sort of cranes
arriving with kind of big concrete
blocks which are being dropped onto the
road and tank traps big metal tank traps
steel tank tracks are also being being
put on the road i went to see a molotov
cocktail factory
and the people who are making the
molotov cocktails were all volunteers
every single one of them was a was a
volunteer there were really dozens of
people down there in a kind of
production line with wine and
beer bottles uh wine or beer bottles or
vodka bottles
making
making molotov cocktails and the other
type of preparation or the
anti-preparations is just people leaving
and i think hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people have left the city
you know how many it's impossible to say
but really the city is very very empty i
went to the uh central station to see
you know there was still lots and lots
of people are leaving and in fact there
still are lots of people uh i mean it
people are basically turning up and it
it it's the timetable there's no more
timetable just that when there's a train
going to the west
the the people who can get on it can get
on it and amongst the people i met
actually in the
station were a group of eight indian
students and um
the students actually
had been living
very close to the tv tower then they'd
heard the explosions and one said uh
this was pretty scary so we decided it
was time to leave and we think this is
probably the last opportunity to leave
because the russians are coming well
ordinary life has really
completely transformed in a week you
know first of all
very few people are working i mean
there's nothing there's nothing nothing
normal is functioning every every
everything is shut in in this city the
only things that are open are some
supermarkets and there are queues in
front of them there are some other
smaller food shops open there are less
cues i have to say today than that have
been in the last couple of days uh there
are still queues outside the pharmacies
that are open as people try and get
prescription drugs or they try and get
um
you know just
any other
medicine but you know everything in life
everything everything's been totally
disrupted i mean considering that you've
got the whole might of the russian army
bearing down on you the fact is that
the ukrainian army by and by is kind of
almost winning by not losing it doesn't
mean that they that they won't be
defeated eventually but it's done
incredibly well far better than anybody
expected and
certainly i mean i far better than
anybody's page and including ukrainians
themselves i think i think ukrainians
themselves have been surprised by how
well their forces are doing and that
means that morale has been
pretty high i think people have been
amazed by zelensky he's just kind of
grown into this
unexpectedly into this kind of inspiring
wartime leader i think kind of
ukrainians are basically shocked or the
ones that i've met are shocked and
delighted by that you know he's a
younger generation he's a man in his 40s
i say younger than i'm comparing him to
to putin of course so what we've seen is
this kind of angry putin and here's
zelinski you know coming out of unshaven
wearing a sort of khaki t-shirt doing a
selfie going we're here it's false news
we haven't fled at all and we're here to
defend ukraine
people like that and in general i think
people are pretty
you know they're pretty amazed and
inspired by uh their president
everybody in kiev is
looking at their phones all the time
which is perhaps no different from
anywhere else in the world but what
they're a lot of what they're looking at
is social media about about the war and
the latest developments and so a lot of
what they're sharing are and a lot of
what's boosting morale are various you
know videos for example in the town of
berliansk which is a small port in the
south occupied by the russians russian
soldiers took up um they were sort of
lining up in front of the um
town hall and uh people
really quite a large crowd was so in
front of them shouting go home go home
go go home another one which is um doing
the rounds which has been inspiring
people you see the car coming out to a
comp pass a convoy of armored cars and
she literally just takes out a molotov
cocktail and chucks it at the tire of
the armored car and then the tyre of the
armored car just bursts into flames so i
think this is one thing that's keeping
people informed and keeping people's
morale up i don't think people really
know what to expect next i think that
everybody in this city
you know
almost everybody in the city was in
complete denial that anything at all was
about to happen uh first of all so
you know now they just have they're kind
of shocked and have you know they're
shocked by what's happened they're
frightened of attacks and you know i as
journalists and
somebody who talks to analysts etc
can freely admit that i got it
completely wrong i never thought that
putin would go this far and launch the
all-out invasion to basically destroy
ukraine in its entirety i thought there
might have been some sort of limited
operation but you know i never expected
this when it comes to what putin's
thinking and what he's about to do
there's only one person who knows what
he's going to do next and and that's
putin and if anybody tells you otherwise
they're lying you know this is a
personal regime
he's in charge and only he knows what to
expect i can actually hear the sirens
have gone off so i think i'm going to to
leave you now
thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]